améliorer l'information communiquer au
mieux sur les nouveautés et surtout
accompagner voici les objectifs que
s'est fixé l'association des diabétiques
des yvelin pour cette année 2015 grâce
au plan élan solidaire qui est un un
plan d'accompagnement qui sera mis en
place au sein de la l'association à
partir de cette année grâce à des
patients qui ont été formés par la
Fédération et qui vont permettre
d'accompagner quotidiennement sous forme
d'atelier sous forme de réunion les gens
diabétiques qui aujourd'hui se posent
plusieurs questions l'antenne yvelinoise
est basée à trappe au sein de l'IPS
comme les années précédentes des
opérations de test de glycémie seront
régulièrement proposé car encore trop de
personnes signignorent diabétiqu nous
savons pertinemment que le diabète est
une maladie qui va malheureusement
s'installer s'accroître au niveau de la
population et surtout le diabète de type
2 on sait très bien que d'ici 2037 le
les chiffres auront probablement doublé
pourquoi nous savons très très bien
qu'aujourd'hui la malbouffe voilà il a
moins d'activité physique on mange plus
en plus la publicité nous pousse à
manger encore plus y compris des encas
et c'est une catastrophe puisque c'est
le surpoids qui entraîne une prise de
graisse abdominale qui est responsable
du diabète de l'hypertension du
cholestérol ainsi que de l'arthrose dans
les petites articulations mieux
contrôler son alimentation ce samedi une
diéthéticienne avait même préparé une
galette une formule plus légère pour
expliquer que l'on peut se faire plaisir
tout en s'alimentant correctement c'est
surtout un un régime le plus équilibré
possible qui contient finalement une
grande diversité d'aliments
avec je dirais des repas suffisamment
riches en féculant centraux avec une
nature de féculant particulière si je
puis dire puisque le plus riche en fibbr
c'est le mieux donc beaucoup de fruits
beaucoup de légumes des féculants riches
en fibres comme les légumes sec les
pâtes complètes et cetera en France
700000 personnes s'ignor diabétique un
enjeu de cruciale l'association milite
d'ailleurs pour la reconnaissance de la
maladie comme grande cause
nationale